[Music]
today is the Jewish holiday of Rosh
Hashanah and as he does every year
President Obama recorded a special
message for the holiday but since it's
an election year I gotta tell you I
watched this thing I think the president
was trying a little too hard this year
to impress Jewish voters with his
greeting as we look forward to the
beginning of the Jewish High Holidays
Sunday night I want to extend my warmest
wishes to all those celebrating the new
year this is a joyful time for millions
of people around the world but Rosh
Hashanah and Yom Kippur are also
opportunities for them they represent a
chance to take stock of our lives look
forward to the coming year with clear
eyes and renewed purpose Michelle and I
wish
[Applause]
[Music]
let's get me for that a day I don't know
I have a good Bar Mitzvahs I'm doing
like an Irish jig and saying that's my
bar mitzvah